what happens in the end of Robin Hood
how does it actually do you know you're
laughing Caleb do you know Seth Zach get
over here come and tell me we found
somebody you got your perspective having
absorbed your content washed you I
consider you the modern-day Robin Hood
okay and before it's me what that means
like tell me your initial thoughts on
this you're smarter than you look
honestly I don't I'm trying to think
right now cuz I don't want to [ __ ]
yeah I think you might be the first
person to say that recently ever maybe
even and I think it's very interesting
because it's crossed my mind
multiple times yeah you well here's what
here's what I'm getting you a long time
ago there were there are these ideas in
these these thoughts and these
collaborations work for the super
successful super rich the Rockefellers
the all these people and what you've
done is you've said I know more you can
look at your Sasha these just started
you can look at the way you do things
and you're making it available to
everybody and if that's not Robin Hood
I don't know what is and to your point
in Sasha's a company I'm building but
like my great legacy in my aspiration to
be someone that gets written about like
Robin Hood is giving it for free if
somebody asked me what are you most
proud of
I'm literally giving away all my best
[ __ ] for free I don't know what else to
say and to your point you're right I go
into the clouds with all these
interesting places and people and things
and I come back every day and I produce
content for the masses for free but and
it's put this for any what's amazing
about that is you've built a business on
or you've built a profitable company of
business on it but you're rising up the
people who believe they never had think
about people that kind of look like me
if you do know who I am a lot of people
that kind of look like me build audience
to the masses but then try to sell to
that audience correct right
here's the $4,000 ebook here's the come
to my master mind what I do is back to
your analogy that's why I thought of it
too I do business with Chase and
Budweiser and Triple A list celebrities
yeah but for the masses it's free yeah
that's crazy
and the masses and and and the
celebrities they sign up for that [ __ ]
they sign up they're onboard because
that's your brand they understand that
they also understand word-of-mouth is
reputation matters like I really know
what I'm talking about
and when I meet anybody and I need by
the way this right we're about we've had
to move this podcast a couple times I've
got this weird day now I come and sit
down say hey I got 20 minutes not 30
right but like for these next 18 minutes
like I'm giving everything I've got like
I'm not thinking about I don't even know
what my next meeting is I don't there's
a million fires I have going on I don't
give a [ __ ] I need to deliver to this
and I think that's what I do well for
any audience whether it's celebrity the
masses client like I'm obsessed with
over-delivering it's why I say yes to
[ __ ] like this in the first place the
fact that you're gonna be able to build
a bigger podcast by leveraging the fact
that I was a guest is the single reason
I'm doing this interview the singular
reason I'm doing this is I know where I
sit and what it will mean for you by
leveraging me yeah yeah that's Metta as
[ __ ] 100% and that's but that's Robin
Hood [ __ ] [ __ ] listen I literally that
was my reaction you're smarter than you
look it's a very very smart observation
and I'll tell you this it actually it's
really funny I judge people on how they
figure me out it's funny where my brain
went when you said it a interesting I'm
pumped that you figured it out B oh [ __ ]
he figures [ __ ] out that is an obvious
you once you don't want compliments till
2009 you asked a question we're in New
York we're in New York
do you love going when you're in town
and he said I love going my bar
I love getting my hair cut we have me
and my barber have great conversations
what was the last great conversation you
had and I'm not talking about the
conversation in front of the in front of
the camera I'm talking about
the last conversation this is the
question had you asked me this 48 hours
ago I wouldn't have known the answer I
would have like thought really fast
yesterday
Travis Cal connect the founder of uber
and former CEO who's you know been out
there stop by were longtime friends I
often talk about passing on uber and
losing out on all those dollars we had a
great conversation like thoughtful as
[ __ ] no cameras to see what him or what
cam no cameras and so so in that in
there in that moment right I don't need
to know what I'll tell you right now in
that moment I was reminded why he was
able to build one of the fastest growing
babies businesses of all time and it
wasn't a business conversation he's just
thoughtful listen I'm gonna pass you
another compliment I like when people
see [ __ ] that other people don't
it's actually how life works let me give
you something I'm hot on right now I do
not think the American Dream should be
buying a home anymore I think it's full
of [ __ ] tell me more that [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah it's a bad use of
upfront capital and it ties you up and
it's just not smart what is it for like
I'm pissed that I own a home yeah I
would literally rent in perpetuity now
and I will like I've decided like I will
never buy another new home uh there's a
bigger College parents are tricked
forcing kids to go to college when 93%
of kids should not go to college I love
when [ __ ] is accepted but it's now
broken because college and buying a home
might have really been awesome and I
actually believe this in 1954 and 1973
the problem is it's 2019 so like I'm hot
on seeing things that are obvious to me
on what's gonna happen next here's what
we do very interesting as a society we
[ __ ] on the new and we put the past on a
pedestal
people buy homes people buy fancy cars
they buy and they go to college for one
reason for significance acceptance but
here's the thing real quick let me tell
you the difference between a Lambo and
owning your own home I'm looking at some
people here we're all looking at each
other right
you just don't know if you own the home
or not like you don't have to know like
I know you're driving a [ __ ] Lambo I
see it but you live in a home I actually
have no [ __ ] clue how much mortgage
you have on that home do you rent it
right I'm telling you this thing and by
light this is my thesis - why it will
fall
I'm not saying fashionable fall fashion
will never fall I got to show you that
I'm wearing fly [ __ ] clouds and dirt
or a Gucci bag or [ __ ] or an Under
Armour's like that's how we express but
on a home I actually don't know if you
own it or you rent it and that's why
it's vulnerable cuz it actually doesn't
matter to the outside person it's not
important it matters that you're in that
home and if you actually play it out it
means people gonna live in much better
homes because if you're not using all
that upfront cash and you're just
renting you can go higher up here being
a fancier place it's very wide oh no
home you know - leave it to your kids
they can rent - oh this is some [ __ ]
up amazing [ __ ] for me I think the whole
thing is gonna go in the next 50 years
it takes time to rebrand by the way
everybody's listening that is how you go
from what was the last meaningful
conversation you have into ranting about
the current state of home ownership in
America my content yes correct
question oh yes what what principles did
your mom teach you and I know she taught
you how many compounds just got that
that you if you had to come up with the
three principles a year
you're gonna pass on to your kids that
your parents talk to you what are those
three principles beautiful so I would
say ha take it's less about principles
number one rule number one
disproportionally over love your child
in parallel in parallel to you building
up that self-esteem you eliminate all
delusion well my mom did that I don't
see most people do is she
wildly made me think I was the best but
anytime it was proven that I wasn't she
acknowledged that I wasn't confidence
not at the expense of reality so you
have two groups of parents the masses
one in secure parents who pass their
insecurities on to their kids and they
[ __ ] other kids thus making kids think
they suck or parents that over coddle
and [ __ ] their kids and give them
eighth place trophies and make them
think like like my son yesterday said
he's gonna dunk and I said you were
never gonna dunk right to his [ __ ]
six-year-old face I'm like dude you've
never dumped he said why I said DNA he's
like what's DNA I'm like ask Alexa right
so that's it it was important for me to
not be like yo you're gonna dunk
he's not gonna dunk and as soon as he
understands that the better that's not
what most parents do so my mom / loved
me and gave me unbelievable self-esteem
but she taught me accountability and
eliminated entitlement do you understand
I'll tell you everything else she did
doesn't mean [ __ ] it's tr7 importance be
kind love it all the amazing stuff hard
work cool I promise you it's two things
build self-esteem make your kids think
that they could do anything until they
prove they can't and then acknowledge
they cannot I'm big on this and that's
what I do with my employees like Go Go
Go and done you can't mine a year off
you're no longer on the video team or
you can't write anymore
like and that's the way it should that's
I love that what is that what does that
do for them in the
in the long term cause I will the effect
is you try [ __ ] and you don't fear
failure yeah the end do you understand
what happens when you stop worrying
about other people's opinions and
failure like everything music and when
you take on full and full responsibility
see optimism and confidence
at the balance of like reality versus
delusion makes you fear failure not
value other people's opinions and have
complete and utter accountability that
[ __ ] gets real good Oh like I when when
you know this is why I pushed like it's
your fault I genuinely think everything
in my life is my fault and it's
liberating as hell you know how fun it
is to know that nobody has control yeah
nobody when you see it's Rick's fault
rick has control one of the questions I
ask my kids every day tell me how you
failed today in the first time I asked
him defensive oh I did work out and look
I'm pissed when I fail so you don't want
to raise people that like just yeah lose
everything like there's there's there's
accountability / Rick you know what my
mom taught me ramifications I'll give
you a good one my mom knew I was gonna
be a [ __ ] winner let's just call it
what it is
but she punished me on the clock four
times a year every [ __ ] report card I
would go down no TV no friends no
Nintendo it was the worst it was [ __ ]
clockwork for a decade she did it cuz
even though she knew it wasn't gonna
matter into macro in the micro it's what
I was doing and if you fail you have
accountability like my graduate is a 2.0
grade point average never went to
college and I'm coaching you've done
your homework you have context like I
love sharing my report
[Music]
I've learned is I flipped that [ __ ] yeah
Papa Doc news old what are you gonna say
about me say naked this all if this
could all play out that we just all roll
naked and like it's and when I say naked
maybe we do up physically rolling let me
promise you something
hypocrisy smells whenever somebody
judges somebody else I always laugh
because I know that they have something
they suck at too or they're hiding too
that's one of the best books I've ever
read mistakes were made but not by me
and that's we live in this world now
every day I wake up at some level
subconsciously or consciously I always
say who the [ __ ] am I you know what I
mean oh yeah
with all the good [ __ ] I think I'm dirt
nobody's gonna give a [ __ ] a year after
I die except for like 11 people like
it's the truth eleven people that are in
that room it's all the people that like
don't know what to do when they see me
at the airport and take a selfie right
like what what put the Macho Man Randy
Savage I'm looking at this [ __ ] like
I love him so much what happened he died
I was [ __ ] up for like four hours
and then the next day yeah I mean listen
the second no Robin Hood says [ __ ] I'm
just doing what I do and you know what
I'm not doing it do you know do you know
what one of you
you you don't know the book robin hood's
no idea this is zak get over here come
and tell me pick one yeah how does Robin
Hood have the story of Robin Hood
alright let me get one speed round two
questions amount alright good thank you
for knowing Raman this is the best
podcast of Belarus for everyone scoring
at home I come from Belarus oh right I
go from for everybody home Belarus to
Queens Queens to Dover Dover to Edison
New Jersey I'm five I go outside in
August 1982 and Eric says and Eric
Godfrey says you are a Jets fan they're
throwing a nerf football around
I'm just getting acclimated to America
right cuz I'm I'm an immigrant
this football thing seems fun we're
throwing around the remembered old here
for you and they're like who do you like
I'm like I have no idea and Eric odd for
he goes you're a Jets fan and that is
how I became a Jets fan so let me ask
please 40 years later yes 40 years later
almost to the day your entire empire
your entire life has been predicated on
this on this one statement right this I
set the goal I guess and look the bell
goes off and I start [ __ ] right I'm
gonna buy the Jets I'm gonna buy the
Jets what happens when
Jetts two very opposite reactions one I
don't give a [ __ ] if I buy the Jets I
just want to try to buy the Jets it's a
very big thing this process this chase
the thrill of the hunt is everything to
me
my intuition is one of two things
happens there is some weird awkward lull
of like micro moment of depression of
like okay I did it
right and it'll be crazy because I'm a
marathon runner so it's not happening
for 20 years and so like over the next
20 years think about how many people in
America are gonna know about this goal
almost everybody right I million know
about it now that's right I mean and so
a lot of people gonna know and then I
hope it quickly goes into and now I have
to [ __ ] win a Super Bowl so my hope
is my intuition is it will quickly
transform into the task at hand so how
many how many stadiums how many how many
jet stadiums do you think you fill with
the people's lives you've changed in
your quest I would say by the time
people's lives and you've changed just
because of you request all this [ __ ]
doesn't happen if it's not for the quest
and so how many lives do you think you
changed by the time you meet you let me
say something I want everybody know and
I'll put it on wax as they say right now
the fact that I get one of the emails I
get a day and I get a lot of them that
says I was at I was suicidal like real
[ __ ] that's heavy yeah that trumps
anything I will ever do professionally
one one person telling you that they
were going to take their life and that
your [ __ ] videos in podcast made them
not is disproportionate greater than if
I bought all 32 NFL teams and I mean
that so you can imagine why I'm such a
happy kid yeah that being said man a lot
man like look I'll be very honest with
you a lot of people I'll put it again on
wax people come up to me all the time
ago Gary you've no idea how many
people's lives you're impacting and I
always hate that because in my mind I'm
like you have no idea how many people's
lives I'm impacting
that I realize I'm impacting and more
importantly how many I'm gonna impact
and by the way this is what makes me so
happy about the way I was parented this
has nothing to do with me
this has to do with the circumstances of
America when I was born and most
importantly my two parents DNA and what
they did with the clay that I was so
when I say that I genuinely think that I
can be a generational person and that's
what I think like make it I'm gonna be
very weird right now I think I can be a
generational person that all four of you
will talk in 45 years that you spend
time with me because I'll be such a jack
Chua Lee believe that I believe it I
think it's going to be many many many
folk I plan on genuinely impacting
millions and millions of millions and
millions and millions if not hundreds of
millions of people because I know am I
in ticket really my only vulnerability
is my health I know my intent my intent
is only to have a statue quote unquote
right like I want to be admired I told
my my sister got emotionally other days
she's just seen how many people I'm
impacting and I said sis November 14th
is gonna be a national holiday you know
obviously was Martin Luther King Day so
is on my mind I was like [ __ ] it why why
not why not why not like what's wrong
like I understand the words coming out
of my mouth and like [ __ ] like it's by
the way you don't get national holidays
for buying the Jets you get national
holidays for moving the culture and when
I say the culture I'm talking humans and
so I'm very excited about my ambitions
and I understand they're audacious and I
understand why some people listening
like oh this guy I understand how it can
sound like big head I promise you if you
peel away the onion it it I wish more
people were doing it I'm with you last
questions like are you gonna go last
question so 50 years from now yes 60 70
years from now you're gone you've left
this earth 150 what what's the
contribution you work that he gave
win-win
[Music]